actually
richard feynman i think said this so
well he
he is also the guy you know really got
me into physics
uh some art friend said that oh science
kind of just
is the party pooper it kind of ruins the
fun right when like
you have a beautiful flowers as the
artist and then the scientist is going
to deconstruct that into just a blob of
quarks and electrons and
and feynman just pushed back on that in
such a beautiful way
which i think also can be used to push
back and make you pre
not feel guilty about falling in love so
here's what feynman basically said
he said his friend you know yeah i can
also
as a scientist see that this is a
beautiful flower thank you very much
maybe
i'm i can't draw as good a painting as
you because i'm not as talented an
artist but yeah
i can really see the beauty in it and it
just it also looks beautiful to me
but in addition to that simon said as a
scientist i see even more beauty
that the artist did not see right
suppose this is a
flower on a blossoming apple tree you
could say this tree
has more beauty in it than just the
fruit the colors and the fragrance
this tree is made of air i'm in roads
this is one of my favorite flying quotes
ever
and it took the carbon out of the air
and bound it in using the flaming heat
of the sun
you know to turn the air into a tree and
when you
burn logs in your fireplace it's really
beautiful to think that this is being
reversed now the
tree is going the wood is going back in
the air and this flaming beautiful
dance of the fire that the artist can
see is the flaming light of the sun
that was bound in to turn the air into a
tree
and then the ashes is the little residue
that didn't come from the air that the
tree sucked out of the ground you know
feynman said these are beautiful things
and science just
adds it doesn't subtract and i i
feel exactly that way about love and
about pistachio ice cream also
i can understand that it even there is
even more nuance to the whole thing
yeah right at this very visceral level
you can fall
in love just as much as someone who
knows nothing about neuroscience
but you can also appreciate this even
greater beauty
in it just like isn't it remarkable that
it came about from from this completely
lifeless universe
just a bunch of a hot blob of plasma
expanding and then over the eons you
know
gradually first the strong nuclear force
decided to combine
quarks together into nuclei and then the
electric force bound in
electrons made atoms and then they
clustered from gravity and you got
planets and stars and
this and that and then natural selection
came along
and and the genes had their little thing
and you started getting what
went from seeming like a completely
pointless universe that we're just
trying to increase
entropy and approach heat death into
something that looked more goal oriented
isn't that kind of beautiful and then
this goal-orientedness
through evolution got ever more
sophisticated where you got ever more
and then you started getting this thing
which is kind of like deep mines um
mu zero on steroids self the ultimate
self play
is not what what deepmind's ai does
against itself to
get better at go it's what all these
little cork blobs did against each other
in the game of of survival of the
fittest you know when you had really
dumb
bacteria living in a simple environment
there wasn't much incentive to get in
intelligent but then the the life made
environment more
more complex and then there was more
incentive to get even smarter
and and that gave the other organisms
more of incentive to also get smarter
and then
here we are now just like like mu0
learned to become world club master at
at go and chess from playing as
itself by just playing against itself
all the quarks
here on our planet the electrons have
created giraffes
and elephants and humans pistachio ice
cream
i just find that really beautiful and i
i
me that just adds to the enjoyment of of
love it doesn't subtract
anything
you